monaco nous sommes en direct avec rémy
réguler directeur du service propreté
environnement de la société monégasque
d'assainissement bonsoir monsieur merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rd france
l'opération a donc débuté ce matin
comment ça se passe bonsoir
effectivement on a démarré ce matin
l'opération de désaffection donc à
rappeler que nous avons la mission de
propreté de voirie et de salubrité donc
c'était tout naturellement qu'il fallait
faire une extension de cette mission de
salubrité pour proposer un nouveau
service à nos usagers donc on a mis en
place deux systèmes voyez les images
donc à la lance donc on a quatre
véhicules motorisés avec des lanciers
qui arrosent les trottoirs avec deux
loups qui contient une solution
bactéricide dont qui ont les mêmes
problèmes les mêmes vertus que les gels
hydroalcooliques et puis on a un
deuxième service de nettoyage avec du
chief est un chiffon et les produits
identiques qui permettent de nettoyer
les mains courantes et les rambardes
ainsi que les boutons d'ascenseurs ou
les usagers sur est susceptible de poser
les mains vides avant la question qu'on
peut tous se poser quand on voit ces
jeunes cg de ce produit ce qu'il
représente une quelconque nocivité pour
les français qui pourraient se promener
dans les rues quelques minutes après
alors pour le coup sont pas des français
ce sont des monégasques puisque c'est la
principauté de monaco mais non il n'y a
pas de nocivité parce que c'est le même
produit que nous utilisons tout au long
de l'année pour désinfecter les filles
essentiellement les tâches lettrage
d'urines où les déchets canins donc
c'est juste qu'on le fait de façon
plus systématique et en quantité
beaucoup plus importante mais c'est
exactement le même produit avec lequel
nos salariés ont l'habitude de
travailler et la désaffection des
ascenseurs nous avons renforcé en vérité
quelque chose qui se pratiquait déjà
tout au long de l'année pour combien de
temps ça va encore durer
c'est la même question vous serez
susceptible de poser aux médecins pour
savoir comme étant savoir encore durer
dans nos suivront l'actualité nous nous
avons mis ce service en place sept jours
sur sept dès nous assurerons tout le
temps nécessaire que la situation le
nécessitera merci beaucoup auraient mis
réguler directeur du service propreté
environnement de la société monégasque
d'assainissement